we start our process of first all
transcribing the uh the conversations if
they're Voice or video we actually
understand what's happening in these
conversations and once you understand
the transcribed then it's a very short
path actually making taking the next
step to actually understanding what is
good what is bad why is that salesperson
succeeding where that salesperson isn't
is this deal going to close or is it not
and we've built a suite of applications
that together make Revenue intelligence
platform that take you hand in hand from
the Inception of a deal stage that we
call prospecting until the deal
completion and the account management
all of that is done within
[Laughter]
[Music]
go P welcome to 20 minute leaders thank
you so much for joining me H I'm really
really happy to have you here Chief R
the officer of gong H such an amazing
company really a company that that led
and and started this this whole cat
which today is so exciting for all of us
I think at this point you know pretty
much it's become a common place for all
of us to be using these different AI
tools to be able to analyze
conversations meetings experiences but
gong really has been a Pioneer in this
space and and a a big pride of of the
Israel ecosystem of course and and I've
always been so fascinated about about
the engineering behind gong and the R&D
and and the novelty of what you're doing
so so thank you again for being here uh
thank you Michael thank you for having
me and thank you for uh the words of
praise for uh gong and our R&D um I'm
really proud to be part of gong and I
feel fortunate to uh be part of and Lead
uh the R&D at gong I joined gong about
four and a half years ago uh gong itself
is has been around for over eight years
um so we started uh doing AI when no one
actually knew what AI meant uh and we're
still doing Ai and we're at the
Forefront of everything that's AI around
conversations understanding them
assigning meaning and also providing
guidance and insights on top of these
conversations so for those of you who
don't know uh the gong story is is very
simple uh it all started with Amit or
CEO that was at the time he was the CEO
of another company and he had a problem
because he wasn't really um uh you know
sure what is happening with uh his sales
team you know he was getting information
from the RM was getting kind kind of
anecdotal information from his uh sales
team but he didn't actually know why
some of his products were not selling he
didn't have the the actual data the lack
of data is something that uh uh is is
problematic if you need to make the
right decisions so um um long story
short he and Alon Rashi are a cheap
product offer so they started gong gong
is all about capturing all the
conversations around the sales process
and conversations that can mean you know
calls emails
um slack messages um sms's everything
around that happens in the uh in the
ecosystem around the uh uh the sales
process obviously we combine that with
the CRM information which gives you the
context around the sales and then we
start our process of principal
transcribing the uh the conversations if
they're um um Voice or video we actually
understand what's happening in these
conversations and once you understand
the transcribe uh then uh it's uh uh
it's a very short path actually making
you know taking the next step to
actually understanding what is good what
is bad why is that salesperson
succeeding with that sales person isn't
um is this deal going to close or is it
not um and we've bu built a suite of
applications that together make uh what
we call the revenue intelligence
platform uh that take you uh um hand in
hand from the Inception of a deal from
the uh uh the stage that we call
prospecting until the deal completion
and the account management all of that
is done within gong now the interesting
thing about gong is that you know uh our
engineering is uh uh you know actually
I'll tell you an interesting story when
I joined gong U about three months after
I joined one of the engineers asked me
you know why is it that you joined gong
you know I came from Akamai an amazing
company I moved to gong a small startup
at the time and he asked me why did I
join gong and and I told him first of
all this is a very blunt question after
I just joined um secondly uh I have
three three good reasons and and what I
answered then is is actually very valid
today as well the first one is that GA
has an amazing technology and we're
looking at scale which is you know it's
it's quite amazing millions of calls and
conversations that we ingest that we
process um you know we're best friends
with AWS we run on AWS mostly on other
clouds as well so the immense uh uh
platform that we've built the resilience
the scalability the stability and and
the various features and and services
that we run is is quite amazing
state-ofthe-art so technology has always
kind of attracted the second thing is
the AI we have kind of world class Ai
and that was you know even before geni
which we're using heavily today and we
can talk about that um and you know
we're using AI we're using NLP we're
using classifier we're using
transcription state-of-the-art uh uh
predictive modeling all of that is part
of our um tradition and part of our
culture and the third thing and this is
where the magic is that at the end of
the day everything is served to the
customer in such a pleasant and simpl to
use way which makes the whole process
and the whole Ingenuity that's within
gong actually seem as though it's very
seamless and easy to consume and use and
make you the seller much better than you
would have been with Al cool so the
combination of uh an amazing technology
uh outstanding AI but simplicity at the
end of the day is something that uh to
me is is unique and very very rare in
our industry and obviously to be part of
this R&D to lead this R&D that actually
takes this and makes this a reality is
uh um to me it's it's uh it's it's
actually almost like a dream come true
what's been happening over the last a
few I guess two three years with
obviously the emergence of of tools in
the context of of deep learning and and
today generative AI how has you know
gangs been operating well before that
and fulfilling on a lot of promises is
in AI before the before this this Spike
now how how has this changed or or
evolved you know gong's gong's Vision or
or gong's day-to-day operations so the
interesting thing is that our vision
hasn't changed um the emergence
emergence of this new technology is now
enabling us to uh um Implement our
vision faster than uh we would have been
uh able otherwise because you know we've
always um taken the the point
understanding conversations
understanding concepts within
conversations uh understanding the
semantics of the conversations uh but
now with Gen uh we can actually take
this uh a step further and actually
generate uh content whether it's a
summarizations of calls or
summarizations of other uh aspects
within you know a deal or uh um a a a uh
an interaction but it's also helping you
with generate you know emails generate
content that you want to send out to
your uh customers and Prospects now if
you combine it all together uh the the
important thing is that you know gen is
used very you know everyone is using it
uh today uh wherever you can but it it's
in order to use it wisely It's a
combination of first of all having the
right data and gong has all the data
because we have thousands of customers
and we have the data so you can actually
generate meaningful insights and
meaningful data uh on top of the data
that you created you uh using geni in a
very you know moderate and wise manner
because gen you know it has many many
limitations and we can talk about that
later it's I think it's a p for is a
whole
episode um it's also very costly if
you're using it at the S scale. gong the
music and it's also not consistent and
the last thing is also understanding you
know what to do when geni just fails you
and because we have an amazing research
group we can actually augment uh the
concepts of J and the capabilities that
J has in order to bring functionality
into the world which genis is incapable
at least at the moment in doing in a
very reliable and consistent manner if
you combine it all together you're
actually getting an experience which is
powered by gen but takes you to a
different level across the whole uh uh
Journey the sales Journey from uh you
know from the uh prospecting phase until
the uh a deal is closed and banag and so
on so
amazing sounds really sounds really
fascinating Now take me a little bit to
your background so you know your
upbringing your your curiosity and
interest in R&D over the time and how
and up until four and a half years ago
when you joined gong H how has this sort
of intersected with your own personal
path and career leading up to here
that's uh that's an interesting question
be you know I I just checked before the
interview and I've been in this industry
for 7 years um and it's you know it
daunts me when I when I say this number
it's uh you know I I don't feel like I'm
older than 27 um but uh uh uh I've been
you know in the Army I was in in an
intelligence scene that before that I
just the regular uh matriculation I
wasn't a computer geek after the Army in
University I studied computer science
and statistics and operations research
and then I essentially started my
journey and the wonderful thing I think
about the uh the uh the job that we do
is that you can actually jump from
domain to domain from area to area and
you can you know obviously you need to
understand the domain but it's actually
like entering a whole new world and
bringing meaning and understanding into
that world so I've I was fortunate to uh
uh in you know beginning of my career I
was part of technomatic which did uh
Robotics and then I was uh uh uh doing
some optimizations around uh um antennas
for the mobile uh industry at at the
time I was doing Insurance software um
in uh actually in the UK so I spent four
years in the UK and then I had a run of
around 12 years doing cyber security so
I was uh um um about five and a half
years at impera uh I managed a group and
then I was Chief Architect got perva and
then after that I was managing the uh um
the R&D of the web security uh division
in at Akamai so 12 years in cyber
security after after 12 years I felt
like I needed kind of a pause I wanted
to uh to check my options I felt like I
I was in my comfort zone so I took some
time off and that's when I met Amon I
never heard about gong before I joined
gong but the minute I heard about the
story it clicked and uh uh it's so you
know kind of enriching uh to uh um you
know I love cyber security but at the
end of uh the the day cyber security you
know it's always you know you chase the
bad guys you try to find a way to uh to
block them to to see how how they
wouldn't be able to attack and penetrate
your systems suddenly moving to gang
it's all about creativity it's all about
creating and enabling the salese to be a
better version of themselves uh it's
like a whole new world so I I feel
fortunate to be a company like o that uh
is so creative and brings so much value
to its customers um and it takes us to a
uh to hold deps obviously with the uh no
we we store I always call it the crown
Jews of our customs so as far as they
you know we have their deal information
their CRM information their conversation
so having a background in cyber security
always helps me obviously helps me to uh
understand how you know we need to
tackle security as well but in general
this whole uh uh you know kind of a uh a
journey um I'm very happy with where I
am and uh I feel like uh gong is is an
amazing Place uh to be and and to grow
incredible thank you for for starting
this with me and for sharing a little
bit of the story of gong and your own
personal excitement I I wish for every
engineer whether it's an entry level
engineer all the way to an engineer Le
leader to to feel the feelings that
you're expressing here about the company
that you're with and that you're helping
lead so thank you again for the time and
for the inspiration obviously best of
luck with everything that's happening
with gong continuing on the rocket ship
and uh thank you for making the time
here my pleasure Michael and have thank
thank you again for having me and uh I
hope we'll we'll be able to do this
again in the future absolutely